hi I'm Matt Welch with my co-author Nick
Gillespie of the Declaration of
Independence ask a libertarian day today
here at reason Andrew Dexter has the
next one via our letters accounts a
question that's on everybody's lips
really my neighbors hobby is hunting and
eating endangered animals would he be
able to do this in a libertarian Society
Nick I would like to believe that in a
libertarian society there would be no
neighbors there would be no animals
there would be no poor people or
anything like that more seriously you
know this is exactly the type of
question which people always throw at
libertarians that one you can't answer
it or you refuse to answer it or you
answer it in a mixed way it's like I
your philosophy has failed we have
endangered animals one thing that we
know that helps endangered animals more
than endangered species list is actually
giving people ownership rights over
animals so in a libertarian society
there would be ownership of more types
of animals and there would be more types
of animals so I think that question
answers itself and not only would your
neighbor be able to hunt and eat those
endangered animals he'd be able to
prepare them with an absinthe sauce or a
cocaine sauce or a heroine sauce and the
world would be a better place and then
Marion